after such a long time
hi so
i'm broadly interested in complexity
quantum computing and
okay
and so far most of my work has focused
on uh creating communication complexity
and some parts of optimization
particularly improving lower bounds for
uh size of cleaner semi-definite
programs and uh discrepancy theory and
strategic processes
so i mean in short talk i will briefly
talk about uh
uh two problems separating uh clay and
very complexity for quantum and
classical
about lower bounds for uh
linear programs for solving the matching
problem approximately
so oops communication complexity and
very complexity about let me briefly
introduce the model
and communication complexity is a very
powerful tool to understand limitations
of different kinds of algorithms
so
abstractly
there are two parties they are given
inputs x and y and their goal is to
compute some function of these inputs f
x y
and to minimize the communication
simultaneously
so this is the standard model introduced
by an er on the 70s
and there are many variations
the bodies can send random messages they
can exchange qubits they can
allow for some error
but it's hard this model is about
understanding this fundamental question
about how much information needs to be
exchanged in order to compute whatever
you're interested in
it's a very powerful tool to identify
information bottlenecks in your
computation because here you sort of
stripped away the issues of you know
computational power
and it's purely information theoretic uh
question now
this has had
a lot of impact in many different areas
in understanding limitations from
information theory distributed computing
streaming algorithms and many others
so in this talk i'll touch on tray
complexity mostly which is a special
which is a subfield of communication
complexity i personally think of it as a
very simple communication model
here this is very useful for analyzing
certain types of algorithms and these
are query algorithms
here the algorithm gets the input as a
black box
and it can make trace to the input and
the black box gives you the answer of
the query
and again the objective is to compute
some function of the input and to
minimize number of queries
simultaneously
there's two types of queries that are
quite uh
useful
the first is you can query bits of the
input you can choose them at random
so what this gives you is exactly a
decision tree
you first query with x1 depending on
that bit you choose another bit query
and so on
and this can be randomized decision tree
second types of query uh
you can query input bits in a quantum
superposition
so and the black box also gives you an
answer in superposition
we don't need to really understand what
this means but this type of query
exactly captures what a quantum
algorithm does
so
so it's quite useful to understand them
again
this model we've simplified a lot of
things we're not counting how much time
it takes to process each query
so sort of we're using the number of
queries as a proxy for the running time
of the algorithm
so the maximum running time of this uh
any algorithm in this model can be at
most m
but still this is
you know
already quite difficult model there are
many non-trivial results here in the
setting
especially useful for an assigning
quantum algorithms because almost
all quantum algorithms are sort of
captured by this setting
and the number of query cells is a very
good proxy of running time for them
so one of the questions that i was
really interested in it was to
understand
uh quantum and classical quake
complexity
uh in their separations
meaning that suppose you want to solve
the same task with either a quantum
algorithm or a
classical randomized algorithm
so how many queries do they need to make
to solve the same task
of course quantum algorithms are always
at least as powerful but they're also
limited because they cannot access the
answer in the same way
after a long line of work starting from
the work of simon peter sure and uh
recently due to tal best separation
for some problem was like constant
versus 10 to the two thirds meaning that
there is some tasks which quantum
algorithms can solve which is constant
number of variables but classically it
needs like n to the two thirds square is
where n is the input lamp
and
we managed to show that the certain
problem
that's called k-fold correlation gives a
constant versus almost linear separation
this is essentially the best you can
hope for in fact this is the best
separation you can hope for between
these two quantities
and this was conjecture to be the
optimal or the best possible separation
by errands and values
let you also mention that in an
independent workshop solve storytelling
they prove the similar separation for a
related problem
and my favorite aspect of
this result is actually the ideas that
go into the proof so that gives you sort
of a nice distinguishing feature between
uh quantum and classical algorithms sort
of tells that you know quantum
algorithms are very good at computing
dense polynomial with a very few queries
but classical algorithms are sort of
restricted because they can only compute
sparse polynomial in some sense
and uh one can make this rigorous and
this is very very some very nice ideas
that are more common in discrepancy
theory in optimization
uh we use them to prove
this result
so this is the first result i was going
to talk about and the second result is
about the size of linear programs
suppose you want to solve a problem in
computer science
by writing down a linear program and
feeding it through a solver
and one classic example of this was from
the 80s when there were some claims that
there is a polynomial size in a program
for the traveling salesman problem
of course they stand out to be false
uh janakakis received them and
abstracted out the main idea that was
being used in these claims
and that's the idea of extended
formulation which is a very powerful way
to reduce the size of linear
programs suppose you want to write down
a linear program for the traveling
salesman problem
right we
expect that whatever program you write
down will have exponential wave
but one way to reduce the size is to
allow extra variable this gives you the
freedom to represent your original
linear program in a higher dimensional
space
what you want is
the shadow or the projection of the high
dimensional object is the original
molecule from this picture you can see
that you know it can help reduce the
size because on top you have five and
you call you need five inequalities to
represent that polygon but the bottom
one is a hexagon so you need six
inequalities
but in height and
of course if you can solve your problem
in a higher dimension space that's going
to be much faster
and it will also give you the solution
problem
in higher dimensional this idea which is
very simple
can help a lot it can reduce the size
exponentially in some cases
that's why it was a long standing open
problem since sienna car gets started
this theory
to show that you know
these are better to understand whether
these
uh sorts of
objects can be very powerful or not
in the last decade there has been there
have been several breakthroughs starting
from the work of fury even start to put
up
uh rothfuss and melina aguero starter
uh we know that
for some np-hard problems and even for
matching problem which we can solve in
parliament time
uh money's exponential linear programs
and even uh semi-definite programs
let me stress that these results they're
really unconditional they don't rely on
any unproven assumptions so they impose
like very strong limitations on these
powerful models
one of my results here was i showed that
for the matching poly though which is
very classic problem in computer science
and combinatorial optimization
if you want to
write down a linear program that gives
you a one plus epsilon approximate
solution
you need and choose one over epsilon n
equal b
so it may not be very obvious by this
number
but
this bound is tight because there is a
very simple linear program
that doesn't even use extra variables
and it has the same size and it gives
you one plus epsilon approximation and
this holds for all values of epsilon so
it generalizes all the previous results
of course the connections to
communication complexity and other
things might not be clear and this is
a long line of work that i won't have
time to talk about here
but this relies on ideas that were
developed in communication complexity to
understand what's called the lopsided
dishonest problem which is very
commonly used in data structure
and those ideas can be
adapted to this setting
with some words
so
at the end with some thoughts on looking
forward
so i mean of course there are some very
interesting questions in these areas
about understanding average case
separations between quantum and
classical grey complexities
improving quantum communication lower
bound by economy information theory
i'm very interested in proving lower
bounds for seven definite
programs for you know solving computer
science problems
of course uh discrepancy theory there
are many beautiful questions that i've
worked on
[Applause]
[Music]
you